楽にしてて良いんだよ
楽にするか～
楽にしてるたくみを輝かせるのが俺の仕事だから
仕上がった？
仕上がってるね
よし！
えーこんにちわ、はじめしゃちょ―です
えーー今！！
酔ってまーーーーす
はいというわけで
この酔ってる状態の僕って至って面白いと思うんですよ基本的に
普段の僕より何倍も
テンションがおかしいっていうかね、ははｈ笑
前も一回やったとおもうんですけども
斉藤さんってやつをねちょっとやっていきたいと思います
まあ斉藤さんどんなアプリかというと
まあ基本的にあれですね
こうなんか
(ピー音)こボロンみたいな
こう知らない人とね対会話をするっていうアプリなんで
この今の僕なら
もうひょっとしたら僕ってバレねえんじゃないかってくらいの気持で今いるんで
今ならなんか何でも話せるなと思って会話も弾むのかなと思って
ちょっとちょっと今からちょちょちょ
はいじゃあちょっとゴリゴリ酔ってるんですけども斉藤さんやっていこうと思います
ではいこう！！
楽しみだな
これで視聴者さんとお話しできたら嬉しいな
もしもし？
(電話が切れた)
は、おまおまふざけんなYOおい
相手　男）も＊＋‘＜＠
もしもし？
え？
男）〇ん〇ん見して
〇ん〇ん？
男）うん
お。俺のかい？
男）え？
俺の？
男）お前のだよ
男）俺はお前が好きなんだ
俺のか
俺の事が好きなのか
(電話が切れた)
もしもし？
相）＊＋＊＋＊＋
え？
男）＊＋＊＋＊＋
あ、こんにちは
男）あのー
はい
相）おいくつですか？
僕、24でｓ
男）どんなお仕事されているんですか？
YouTuberです
男）ほんとですか？
はい
男）はい
男）え
男）なにしゃちょーですか？
はじめしゃちょーです
(電話が切れた)
今ですね
酔った勢いで
斉藤さんをやってるんですよ
はっはっはっ
女）どうしたん
いやー
酔った勢いで
はっはっはっは
女）やばいやん
女）怖い
怖いですか
はっはっはっ
おー！(電話が切られた)
あー！もしもしー！
(電話が切られた)
ピィーーーーヤ！！
もしもし！
今死ねって言ったな
死ねって言っちゃダメなんだぞ！！
今日も一日
いいことがあるといいね
ハム太郎
女）すいません
はい
女）声が
女）ふふｆ
女）はじめしゃちょーに似てますね
バレてしまったようだな
はっはっはっはっはっはっ
(電話が切れる)
ばれたぞ
たくみんバレるよ
た）んー？
聞こえてますか？
はい
今日は8月の15日
今日も元気に明るく楽しい1にｔ
(電話が切れた)　あれえ
いろんな人がいるねー
女）あ、もしもし
もしもしー
こんにちは
女）あ、もしもし
はい
女）こんにちは
こんにちは
こんにちはこんにちは　ちわ
女）お兄さん
女）しゃべり方
え
女）はじめしゃちょーに似てますね
なんで分かった！
ちょっと待ってそんな分かる？
ばれる率高いでしょ
なんでそんな分かる？
＊＋＊＋＊こんにちわあ
男）＋＊こ
男）ななんだってえええ
男）なんてしゃべってるんだあい
僕もわかない
男）＋＊＊わからないー？
男）どこに住んでるんだいー？
にほん
ジャパニーーズ
ピーポーーーーー
男）いぇーーーーい
いぇーーーーい！
HELLO
女）HELLO
マイ　ネイム　イズ　だいすけ
(電話が切られた)
ぷーーー
男）もしもし
あー、もしもし
うわっ
(電話が切れる)
天罰が下るがよい！
男）もしもし
ＨＥＬＬＯ
男）ＨＥＬＬＯ
わ、わwhat your name?
my name is 清水
ノー
(電話が切れた)
バルス！
男）もしもし
もしもし
♪
間違えたとかあんのかい
(電話切る)
ふふ、間違えたってどういう
間違えたってどういうことだよ笑
こんばんは
男）はい、こんばんわー
あなたを闇の世界へ誘うもの
ダークソーサだ
男）え、誰..
男）ダークソーサだ？
そうだ
男）どうしたの？
あなたを闇へ誘うもの。それが私。
男）ダークソーサだ
そうだ
男）それで？
今からあなたを闇へ誘う
参ったか
男）参った
男）参った参った
男）参ったーー
そうだろーはっはっはっはっ
男）はっはっはっ
はっはっはっはっ
はっはーはっはー
男）はー
はーー
(二人で)はっはっはっはっはっ
うーー
男）ういー
わんわん
男）わんわん
うーー
男）にゃー
男）わんわんわんわん
うーー
男）うーわんわんわんわん
男）んふふ
男）にゃー
お
わんわん
モッツアレラチーズ
男）うえーい
男）モッツアレラチーズ
モッツアレラチーズ^^
男）モッツアレラチーーズ
モッツアレラチーズ⤴
男）モッツアレラチーーーーズ
モッツアレラチィーーーーーズ
男）モッッツアレラチ⤵ーーズーーー⤴
はぁっ！
あーあーあーあーあーあーーー
モッッッツアレラ　チィーーーーーズッ
男）www
男）モッッツアレラチィーーーズ
ああぅ
モーーーーッツ
モォッ
ッツアレラ
ぶわぁーーーお
男）wwww
男）モ～～～～ッツアレラ　チ～～
(電話を切る)
モッツアレラチーズ
男）ブルーチーズ
レアチーズ
男）ブリティッシュチーズ
wwww
参った
男）やった
ENDING♪